you could coined one of the most famous
catchphrases in history I pity the fool
what's interesting is I read an article
with you once where you said that when
you pity the fool you consider that an
an act of kindness oh yes oh yes oh yes
the idea was cities that pay the fool
means I want to kill the guy no no no no
when you pity somebody who's showing the
mercy cuz I didn't start this pity stuff
it was in the Bible you know you find
pity so many times in the Bible in food
so many times so I put them together
pity the fool because a lot of a lot of
guys in the Bible was asking for pity
yeah you know and another was saying I
did a foolish eight right so I'll put it
together but ever eyes you get all this
research or you know you came up with
this right mr. t you trademark there is
likely the fool exactly so what happens
if someone uses that in the commercial
oh man oh my people gonna be older oh
yeah oh yeah right that's part of mr. t
retirement all right
that's when that's when she comes and
stands for take you to court
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah my turn my
courage me wait let me wait no food to
do something like that all right
oh yeah so if someone else is if you saw
me and I did a commercial and I when I
pay the fool that doesn't eat cocoa
puffs what would happen to me no I
wouldn't you know cuz we buddies I will
call you up say it gonna yeah
you know I figured me you could work it
out before we go to court
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you